you can change the world to meet your
values when you are in government you
can't when you are in opposition getting
into government has to be the first and
sole purpose in any political party I
was there in the 1980s when the hard
left held a dominant position in the
Labor Party when Labour had 18 19 years
of continuous opposition and I learnt
the hard way really that extreme left
politics just didn't connect to the
voters but I was also there in 1997 and
through the years of the Blair Brown
government's when I saw what impact one
could have when we controlled the
leaders apart
I am virtually the lost Jewish woman
Labour MP left standing
if we don't learn the lessons of why we
have lost the 2019 election if we allow
the error to korban to be rebecca wrong
bailey did you stand up at any point and
call it Alice I did what was that you
know no it wasn't the idea that we will
ever get a Labour government certainly
in my lifetime or disappear I mean if I
had a majority of a team Margaret I know
just think just even just one thing
you'd be like giddy like a child in a
sweetshop the last four years we have to
be honest with people it's been a
[ __ ] disaster for the Labour Party
the last thing I wanted more more
Corbett we said last time you wanted to
win didn't you I've known Corbin since
82 if there's one thing he really
believes in it's all that massive world
view which is hostile to NATO hostile to
the states he leads to the anti-semitism
I didn't break rank and tell people was
going in the shadow cabinet on this or
anything else because I don't think you
should
yeah I've considered my position in the
labour party over the last few years to
be honest I put myself forward versus
frankly the worst job in the world
position for me I'm going for Jess
Phillips when I've seen the others
against a lot of most sort of
traditional politicians we need someone
who can stand up as if Boris Johnson and
where his government in his face the
Labour leadership race is narrowing from
five to four this time that person isn't
me
yeah Jess was due to come and speak at
the event yeah she's gone back to back
yeah yeah
we've sent her some flowers what could
have been ah goodness that is really
hard I mean I watched Jesse's video and
it's really moving and I wanted to cry
when I watch that for I think what the
Labour Party's lost but I'm a sort of an
old old fighter that's the real truth so
I'm gonna carry on fighting and I just
want to see what there are candidates as
three of them really that I'm looking at
who can fill the void that Jesse's
departure and has created when I've seen
the others against a lot in the sort of
traditional politicians men in suits
quite often
he's triangulating like mad somebody
said to me I don't mind what he does as
long as he wins beats Rebecca long
bailing and I thought you know Toni
never did that Toni was completely
straight completely honest
it's a different way of doing your
politics so it's clear lying to get the
job and then we then change that's what
this person was saying to me as a way of
promoting care I mean I said so
I know so it's sort of in a way you
don't think right those people who chose
to join verman probably a lot of left
now a young idealists who for whom at
the time Corbin was a message of hope
they are the ones who don't like the
politics don't like the anti-semitism
and don't might be unto Europeanism your
star should see this in whose nomination
Kearse Dharma you know momentum is
cracking up it's sort of you know the
old trots we'll all go for Rebecca as
will the out of jade fat-bellied
beer-bellied trading and Barons no no
boys Owen is a ridden pro-european years
actually I am cross because he's 40
minutes late you know everybody is busy
and you just you know if you're busy
people make me busy people
I mean don't piss them off for being
late anyway we are where we are gone why
do I talk to him because Owen is a
Corbin supporter and also he's been a
pretty constant critic of the Blair
Brown years active labor in power and in
government I want to challenge him a
little bit on that too you are very late
I have been in the labour party very
long time longer than I I don't indeed
so I remember the eighties which you
know we're very uncomfortable where you
used to go along to Labour Party
meetings and if you dare to put up your
hand in something you believed in so all
you were doing was following your values
which may have been different
there was intolerance of it people would
shout abuse of you I had bricks thrown
at me during discussions on cuts and
local government I did I've had death
threats sir I've had it all my life and
I got it from the left then the Labour
Party then went through under the Blair
Brown years which you like to dismiss I
don't dismiss okay but like the Labour
Party when but I remember under
well I'm really P so it went through a
really tolerant period when you could
get up and you could descent within the
party that wasn't my experience at the
time by the way it was experience for
the victors but anyone to the left you
wouldn't have been shouted at it rots
all the time uses a catch-all term for
anyone vaguely on the Left okay that was
not my experience there was a much more
open discourse you guys not that because
you want that you're on the winning side
of course you'd won your side one and
the left felt ostracized that's right
really irritates me really irritate it
does irritate me because you know here
you are
dude I left I went blank of the Labour
Party that's just that I don't know what
it means because I think your definition
of left which is around you know big
state nationalizations Democratic
Democratic know it was joking no I mean
I've just been through recession Owen
okay in my party the whole triggering of
that process was by the few to defeat
the will of the many so all this stuff
about we're fantastic democratic the
Labour Party now is the most you want
election centralized bullying okay
obviously strongly disagree with that
and I don't I don't think democracy is
bullying you wouldn't your selection you
won your you won your selection fair and
square because the many vote of you
because I went into it I in the run-up
is completely crazy
it distracted me from what I should have
been doing because it was obvious we
were going to get a general election and
I should have been out there in the
community reconnecting with my vote can
I ask this I think ingredient because
here we are if we are some different
wings of the labor family let's just
pull it that way but it's interesting
we're having this argument or discussion
or whatever you want to call it when
actually if we're honest and humble
neither of our brands of politics have
any easy answers at the moment and the
reason I say that is you will talk about
the 90s Blair and brown and so on a
period before the financial crash a
period of rising living standards there
was a financial bubble at the time which
seems to be generating ever rising
living standards the problem is at the
moment there is a general crisis of
social democracy
and there was no where are either of us
can point to on a map and say AHA here's
where my brand of politics is truly
truly flourishing because Quinton is
defeated by Trump that's why I look at
this mess now I mean what's the answer
to that I don't have one I don't have
one either I mean that I agree with you
about the challenge I think it's really
tough I think it's really really tough
how you build on the eternal values
which I hope you and I do agree about
and challenges which I think eat a
massive insecurity so the changing world
of work and artificial and climate
crisis climate crisis those are really
tough challenges for the left but that's
one that I would love to learn in fact
on that that's what I'd be fascinated to
hear because I think even some more
perceptive thinkers on your flank of the
Labour Party's core we have flag what it
is is that that wing was politically and
intellectually exhausted in 2015 what I
would say is the challenge facing anyone
who does become leader is huge with a
culture war which has opened up in
British society which brexit both kind
of encouraged but also reflected and
that has wreaked havoc in Labour's
electoral coalition and I don't think
anyone from whatever wing of the Labour
Party has an easy answer for how they
bring younger people from economically
insecure and have very strong
progressive values which they think are
under attack with older people who
rightly ever had their triple-locked
pensions protected home ownerships gone
up and they feel quite socially
conservative and how Labour wins some of
those over and keeps their younger
voters is a real challenge and I think
we have to all of us be humble about
discussing analysis and I just hope that
there can be a civilized
non blaming debate about what are really
really tough issues that these are
probably the toughest philosophical
political issues that I have confronted
in my very long political life hi Pfizer
its Margaret Hodge
listen I'm ringing you about next
Thursday when we've got the meeting to
do the nomination for leader I mean this
is really
important getting the right leader you
know if we want to bring the party back
to sensible labor politics you know okay
Thanks so so much and see you on
Thursday bye bye well I don't know where
sayonara is are you good because
otherwise it can be kale we're gonna be
here forever otherwise Cameron I really
believe that the carbon project the
socialist manifesto the return to a true
labor values has actually been a really
good success you wanted to win didn't
you are you a member of the Labour Party
are you them up now and close the world
is kiss almond is number one so he
wouldn't so the continuity candidate
it didn't get anywhere tonight and you
know I've always said when you know
there are arguments for DISA
and for clear eyes of marginal Egon for
ISA but I'm absolutely delighted that
we've got sensible kind of a sensible
candidate through from this considerably
I don't you can just sort of say oh well
let's assume Corbin isn't gone because
the party is I think the party has
changed fundamentally you can see this
in the leadership election going on now
none of them can quite bring themselves
to say that
Corbin ISM was a disaster jeromy's this
sort of sainted figure I mean I agree
with you about that I've so agree with
you because there's a central dishonesty
in the non Corbin candidate yeah you
know okay and if you compare that to
Kinnick Kinnick when he fought for the
leadership of the Labour Party in the
Angels came from the left but he was
completely honest about the sort of
reform that had to be undertaken I mean
Neil was very good at kind of pinnacle
management by I had a very interesting
exchanging the care when he launched his
leadership video and it was you know -
striking poll tax and I sent him a
message say I'm really pleased that I
gave most of my adult life to trying to
help the Labour Party into power three
terms in office so that a future leader
could launch his campaign where the only
mentions of that period of labour in
office were the Iraq war and cutting
asylum-seekers benefits and it's just
playing into that Corbin Easter agenda
so he then sent me a message back I said
yeah well I'm doing this new thing now
where I'm saying we shouldn't trash the
last four years and we shouldn't trash
the last Labour government like they're
equal the last four years I get why he
can't say it but we have to be honest
with people it's a it's been a [ __ ]
disaster for the Labour Party
the elections alone do disaster I think
too much of our politics is about saying
oh this is what people want to hear
let's say that to them and play it back
to them so when you did a bit of that
DHS you did another you did the
message can be simple but it's got to be
underpinned by something that is real
real policy real stuff real choice real
decision if you look at our last
election
Corbin or Johnson the country was
repelled by the choice but in the end
realize well we have to make sure we
have to choose one of them one of them
is gonna be Prime Minister who's it
going to be go beyond that so we get a
charismatic leader I feel more confident
than you do that we're going to get a
change of leader and that will try and
prospect oh yeah it's definitely gonna
be a change Rebecca long day it's
alright
okay it's my view my name is Rebecca
long Bailey I think that's the end I
agree I think we might as well go home
some of the values that now inform
people's voting decisions are really
hard for us to tackle so let's assume
we've got a charismatic leader who can
connect to people how are they going to
tackle the issues of immigration which
is which is really tough which we had to
think about we didn't do we didn't
really get to the bottom of and how are
they going to tackle tax-and-spend in an
environment where people don't want that
how can I create a more equal society
out of this brief that I've now been
given this is why I think it goes beyond
what Corbin ISM it goes beyond who
actually becomes the leader you know
look I can't stand Johnson on many many
levels but one of the reasons he won is
that he gave a kind of albeit riddled
with lies and all that he gave a sense
of kind of optimism Yambol and hope so I
would say take all of those issues that
you mentioned climate change being the
biggest I think a leader who came out
now and was truthful about the
consequences of climate change and
really led on them and really fought on
them gives themselves a fighting chance
the other thing that's changed I think
the left/right arguments are less
straightforward than they were I hate
this term left right I mean I believe
we're trapped in it don't underestimate
the impact of Trump in framing the
debate right around the world the the
whole kind of nationalist populist
language yeah that is is easier to
articulate it yeah easier to get people
to resonate with so but the way you
frame a debate is to decide that is the
debate I'm going to frame now at the
moment I feel that there it's being
framed within this historical analysis
of the Labour Party much yeah terrible
yes the other thing that fills me with
hope is a leader we elect now is
unlikely able to become Prime Minister
given the mountain we have to climb back
you think it's so volatile that we
couldn't bring it back yeah I think
things are so volatile things move so
cool well I think some of the most that
is that will definitely be the case if
the leader authority late Playsafe so if
I were leader tomorrow what would I do
to create something true to my lasting
values relevant today that gets me a
mature okay well neither you and I would
be elected because I think we would both
start from a position of saying we have
to be absolutely honest about how we've
got to this position and we have to be
absolutely honest about the challenges
we face to get back so I would build it
on understanding and accepting that the
right the nationalist populist right is
going to be very difficult to beat and
then saying they will not be beaten by a
ping them they won't be beaten by
beating them halfway
they have to be beaten by a bigger
better bolder more optimistic vision
about what Britain can be this idea that
you know it's all good getting the right
northerner as a response to the north
just putting a bloody old Etonian in
power they won the referendum they won
the election they have a lot more power
than they did now the difference I think
between when I was with Tony and
Cummings now with Johnson I never really
had an agenda of my own I had things I
agreed with and things that I disagree
with but I kind of I didn't see my
position as being there for
my agenda go on your back in the Labour
Party you've got a vote Alistair how
would you use it for the leadership yeah
but assume I think probably here
probably care and do you think you can
turn it round I really don't know
because I think is I think a lot of
these top jobs in politics I don't think
you really know until they get to them
my fear is that the only way he can turn
it round is by doing something different
from what he's telling us he's going to
do now well I think the short answer is
I don't think any of us know yet whether
they've got in them I've taken over the
chair of the parliamentary chair of the
Jewish labor movement really because
everybody else has done it has gone
scary but it's true and there are very
very few Jews now on the latest night in
Parliament and probably I'm the only one
who's running put my head above the
parapet around my Jewish identity and
also it's symbolic of what the Labor
Party ought to be all about how we're
going to build that confidence quickly
it was really uncomfortable for me
during the election going out and trying
to persuade Jewish people to vote Labour
are they not going to come in No
question
we're going to bring them on together
it's fine
[Applause]
thanks Mike and thanks for giving me the
opportunity to say a few words because I
am virtually the last Jewish woman
Labour MP left standing if you look
after the war and the force of the
mid-seventies most Jewish MPs were
Labour MPs because being in the labour
party was the natural home for Jews
sadly we're not in that position today
I hope the candidates I was hoping
they'd be in when I said all this but
they're not so maybe some of you can ask
me the questions after I think for all
of us I felt at the last four years for
me have been the most miserable
challenging and lonely years in my
nearly 60 years of membership of the
Labor Party the history of the last four
years is being rapidly rewritten by
those who are seeking our support and my
commitment to you is I will not cease
fighting until we are clear that we have
eradicated anti-semitism from the soul
of our great leader
I know all of these individuals
extremely well and they're all
thoroughly nice thoroughly decent people
and they're doing a very tough job and
we have to treat them with respect
because you know we're just bloody lucky
to have people in this country prepared
to put their necks on the chopping block
for our well lucky did you stand up at
any coins and call it ours I did what
was that you know no it wasn't my IDs
but I did speak in Shadow Cabinet about
this a few times and believe that you
speak out and speak in private and you
try and get something done but if you
can't get something done and it's still
wrong then you leave and you speak out
and you speak up and you make sure that
something is done this was the big fight
for the heart is sort of a raiding party
if a Corbin follower succeeds Corbin
then I think the position for Jews in
the Labour Party long term is completely
untenable digest you are a breath of
fresh air and that's why I'm sure you've
got a great future in the labour party
but for me that's why I wanted you as
the leader that you were authentic you
told it as it is that you were brave and
that you really really could connect
with ordinary people and for me and all
the battles that I've done through my
life maybe the battle against the BNP I
understood from that the absolute
importance of being both honest but
really listening acting and connecting
and that's why you're so important to
the labour movement and will be in the
future well the idea of standing up
regardless of the struggle regardless of
how difficult something is that sort of
courage and that sort of bravery it has
felt sometimes as if that has just no
longer been part of the battle
that we had to you know agree with the
crowd regardless of what the crowd felt
yeah totally I think I really feel
strong is in the anti-semitism fight oh
gosh yeah you know it was the women oh
it was totally and I will never forget
you
just after Luciano Berger had decided to
leave the Labour Party and you rushed
over to sit behind her
so you showed some solidarity with her
it's always been the women and then you
demonstrated in that very clear way that
even though she felt forced out she was
still your sister she will labor women
standing shoulder to shoulder is the
reason that I no matter how hard things
get within the Labour Party the reason I
cannot walk away is because my life was
genuinely changed by the fact that loads
of labour women came in here in 1997
they never ever forgot to remember me
people like me in the community also
exactly you sure start your tax credits
your childcare I will never ever be able
to pay about the debt of the fact that
my children have more secure life than
they would have had they been born under
a Tory government and so the idea that
has been presented to us for the past
four or five years whether it's a Bronte
Semitism whether it's over women within
the labour movement whether it's over
sexual harassment they've been like
you're disloyal for struggling and I'm
not no I'm here to help the labour body
I didn't do it for me I did it because I
believe it's the right thing for a man
actually I joined the Labour Party
because it's horrible to fight it fine
how do you think you square the circle
between you know the traditional
working-class support that we used to
have and we want to get back and the
more middle-class liberal support that
comes out of the city it's absolutely
not my experience of working class
communities in the Midlands and the
north that they all hate immigrants or
that they all they're never this the
Labour Party being the party of the
self-interest of the masses has been
lost because we stopped being able to
say the word self-interest and my Nana
and granddad my great-grandfather was
one of the people who set up the
Independent Labour Party in Birmingham
and it wasn't because he was and big
ideas about the
way that the world should be it was
because he lived in a slum and he didn't
want to live in a slum anymore yet
self-interests and my nan and granddad's
politics was about moving out of the
slum and getting a decent wage it was
self-interested it wasn't so that
everybody has enough it was for them and
their families to be able to do all
right
and then their children the baby boomers
my parents they had enough to care about
everybody having enough and then it
became an ideological movement yeah
rather than a self-interested one
there's absolutely no reason why you
cannot square ideologically wanting
everybody to have enough with the idea
that you and your family feel like you
haven't got enough and need it those two
things my nan and my mom there is cut
from the same cloth they were the same
exactly the same sort of person they
both would have voted labour until they
died and it was rooted in something
completely separate for both of them
that is the coalition I think we think
it's a harder job than it is to make
people in bassett law feel the same way
as people in Brighton they essentially
do I feel like this should now be an
opportunity to look up to the country a
little bit more to look up from the
script I don't feel that there's any
sense that world leaders are getting
together to deal with the pandemic I
don't quite know how he's gonna rise to
that I think that they're connecting
with the country is vitally important
now I think that he will inevitably get
a bounce also I hate this because it is
got so much sort of horrible sexist
connotations he looks the part doesn't
they and so a number of people who say I
hate it's a number of people who have
said to me you gotta vote for care
because just think every Boris implodes
you trust care opposite you why wouldn't
you trust a woman well well quite
absolutely but it's got good air house I
make I mean he has got good hair my
lovely hair he's always ticked that box
but that is a tiny box of connecting
with the public I mean I think we can
all understand that the candidates have
got to build a majority within the party
right
but once of election
is over they've got a turn to the public
and they've got to be bold and that
means not sticking to what's happened in
the last five years it means I'm
breaking from that yeah and the last 20
years you have to think is that what you
accept I agree with that but the thing
that really really pisses me off is like
enough the last like a month early why
were just like off the record office
when the government's declaring it all
brilliantly by herself in the face of a
Boris Johnson government he's got a
majority of 80 and is he doing anything
with it
I mean if I had a majority of 18
Margaret I know just think even just one
thing you'd be like right okay we're
gonna end child poverty we're gonna sort
the social care crisis you would just be
like I'd be like giddy like a child in a
sweetshop so Jess it may have been a bit
too early this time where it may have
been the wrong time but I want you to
stand again so the Labour Party
leadership you've got to promise me
you're gonna go I mean I promise you
that I will have a go but regardless I
promise you that I will always try and
make sure that I have the biggest role
that I can have in making the Labour
Party the best it can be
thank you you're welcome thank you
I did say to people before the election
hang on in there because the battle
after the election will be the most
important battle in the life of the
Labour Party I now think that the way in
which the next leader chooses to use
that position will be the most important
[Music]
[Applause]